in the meantime we're happy to have one
of the very few people
in american journalism who understood
exactly what was going on long before
most of us did
and wrote about it extensively he is
glenn greenwald who writes on sub stack
and he's a frequent guest on the show
we're honored to say glenn thanks so
much for coming on
so i think there are a couple of levels
here
i have learned in the last week that in
washington the fact that the federal
government is reading your emails is no
big deal and you're like a nut case for
even noting it or being bothered by it
there's no expectation or privacy
whatsoever
but i think and you would know but the
federal law is pretty clear on this
if nsa captures information sent
privately by an american citizen they
have to keep that citizen's identity
secret
unless they go through a process to
quote unmask it so it seems very clear
to me that they did exactly what they're
not allowed to do
yeah i think there's two important
components one is the first one that you
just referenced which is that
if they were doing this perfectly
legally meaning
they intercepted your email
communications with legal authority
because you were talking either to the
russian government which they obviously
are allowed to spy on
or to a target in the united states
where you were using as an intermediary
and they learned that way that you were
communicating with the russians about
the possibility of an interview with
putin
they have the legal obligation to
conceal your identity and make sure that
nobody knows
that you were the one that was speaking
to the russians the intelligence that
they care about is that the russians
were doing something not with whom they
were speaking so clearly
there was either a failure to hide your
identity as required by law which is
illegal
or an attempt to unmask it after it was
minimized which also would be a crime
given that there's no national security
justification for doing it
you know there's something much more
serious tucker which is when the nsa
spies
on american citizens speaking to foreign
nationals or foreign officials even when
it's legal that's a very great power
so there are real limits on what they
can do with that
it is one of the gravest crimes in the
u.s code
to for the nsa to leak the contents of
communications that it intercepts
between a foreign official and an
american citizen
and i think one of the things that got
overlooked is that in 2017
when general flynn who was in the
crosshairs of the entire deep state
under obama was speaking with ambassador
ambassador to kislyak
they leaked the contents of that
communication intercepted communications
between a russian official and the
incoming national security adviser
to the washington post it was as grave
of a crime as it gets under the u.s code
to this day not only don't we know who
did the leaking no one
cares because they hate general flynn
they're he's not their ideology and
therefore they think it's justified
that's the reaction here oh it's tucker
carlson
he's a conservative we don't like him
and so we don't even care
if the nsa was doing this but it is
illegal to do either of those two things
well and and flynn i mean i know and
it's not an attack on flynn
or anything but like so many people he
was under attack and he went on the
defensive and then he remained silent
and he didn't articulate his own case
and maybe his lawyers told him not to
or something but if you were persistent
in demanding look as an american citizen
you may not like my politics but you're
not allowed to violate my rights and
break the law
i mean i wonder if you could force them
to
admit what happened and then you could
force some accountability i mean no one
in these agencies
brannon clapper they lied under oath
before congress we played the tape a
thousand times nobody cares nobody does
anything could you actually force the
system
to hold these unaccountable leaders
accountable for once
the problem is there are so many
doctrines that the security this
security state has existed
since the end of world war ii they've
been operating in secret and with no
democratic accountability
for eight or nine decades now dwight
eisenhower when he left office warned
the country
about the dangers that they pose so so
many times when people have gone to sue
the nsa for illegally spying on them
they have
doctrines that they use they'll say it's
too secret we can't have courts looking
into what we did because that will
jeopardize national security and then
courts dismiss the lawsuit
or they'll say tucker carlson can't
prove
that we actually spied on him therefore
he has no standing to sue
and courts will dismiss that as well the
remedy here
is for congress it's congress's
responsibility to exercise oversight
how the executive branch spies on people
and for so long congress has been either
afraid
of the the the nsa and the cia or worse
subservient to them and you're right it
has been the republican party
along with democrats that has long
venerated these agencies and
only under trump did they start to
realize actually these
agencies interfere in our politics and
threaten our democracy in really
pernicious ways
and they need to take that knowledge
that they learned over the last five
years
and use it to get to the bottom of what
happened here so i spoke to and this is
not speculation it's a conversation i
had personally
face to face with i uh someone i thought
was a very powerful member
of the committee that oversees the
intelligence agencies in congress i
can't be more specific but
this is a true story two years ago told
me to my face
that his communications were being
monitored
by the intel agencies the ones that he
was supposed to be overseeing and that
he didn't dare text me
because he knew they were reading his
text and i thought to myself this system
is completely dysfunctional
if the person is supposed to be holding
them accountable is afraid of them
then who's in charge here it sounds like
they are
we we learned this is one of the big
scandals of the obama administration
that when the senate intelligence
committee was investigating the cia
and their role in the interrogation
program at guantanamo and elsewhere
john brennan cia spied on the leader of
that senate investigation which was
dianne feinstein the c.i.a was spying on
the senate
as the senate was investigating the cia
the the most significant exchange i
think i've talked about this on your
show before
was three days before trump was
inaugurated chuck schumer went on the
rachel maddow show
and rachel maddow was very upset that
trump was insulting the cia
because she loves the cia and chuck
schumer said the thing you're not
supposed to say allowed which is
trump is being stupid because everyone
knows that if you challenge the
intelligence community
they have six different ways to sunday
to get back at you and that's exactly
what they proceeded to do over the next
four years was undermine his
administration
people in washington are petrified of
the security state and that's why they
exist with no democratic accountability
well we have to push back and by the way
if they find a meth lab in my basement
it's not real
just so you know just kidding sort of
glenn greenwald
i'm sure you've been worried about that
for years great to see you tonight thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else